a la selva amazónica de ecuador fue el
destino del premio goldman este año
otorgado a dos indígenas de la etnia
cofán álex licitante y alexandra narváez
por su histórica victoria judicial que
permitió proteger sus territorios
sagrados de un mal común para los
indígenas la minería de oro
recibir el premio goldman simboliza la
esperanza espero seguir con esta lucha
para cuidar la amazonía y la vida este
premio es un símbolo de la fuerza
colectiva de los pueblos indígenas por
la defensa de nuestro territorio y de
nuestras vidas por el futuro de nuestros
niños este 2022 los ecuatorianos han
sido los únicos latinoamericanos en
llevarse el considerado como el nobel
del medio ambiente un logro nada fácil
que comenzó en 2017 cuando narváez formó
una guardia indígena para monitorear y
frenar las actividades ilegales en su
territorio con lo que descubrieron
campamentos mineros improvisados al
enterarse el licitante sanador
tradicional y estudiante de derecho se
unió narváez y empezaron a la lucha
juntos
tras meses de batalla e investigaciones
con drones en 2018 consiguieron anular
52 concesiones ilegales de extracción de
oro protegiendo así 32 mil hectáreas de
selva tropical virgen y biodiversidad en
la comunidad de thin and go según los
ganadores es un premio para todos los
pueblos indígenas de ecuador que llevan
años luchando contra la deforestación de
su territorio por las actividades
petroleras y mineras